dr uncle jensen liegt um die ganze welt
und bringt schwer verletzte urlauber
nach hause
ich versuche zu ereignet
sie ist ärztin über den wolken
immer für ihre patienten da aber man so
langsam in tritt
auch unter erschwerten bedingungen
es ist
ein job unter hochdruck bei dem jede
sekunde zählt
vor schreck
verflogen
wohin zwischen leben wurde die erste
haben und die haben wir heute
wir sind minimal alter nicht
emotional und tod
kurz vor dem plan deutschland plötzlich
patientinnen und patienten in
deutschland leider verstärkt und ich
glaube solche männer hat jeder kollege
mal mitgemacht bild unterwegs mit der
flugambulanz
[Applaus]
[Musik]